en vídeos anteriores he comentado que
los vectores propios de alguna
transformación de una matriz en general
forman bases interesantes para esa
transformación o esa matriz es decir son
son vectores
sectores básicos interesantes forman
bases interesantes todos básicos bien
esto qué quiere decir
pues sí tengo una transformación lineal
t que va de rn en rn y yo supongo que te
se puede representar mediante una matriz
a es decir que la transformación
aplicada al vector x es lo mismo que
multiplicar la matriz a por dicho vector
x donde a es una matriz de n por n bien
pues ahora supongamos supongamos
supongamos que ah
la matriz a tiene
tiene n vectores propios n vectores
propios que son linealmente
independientes
es decir el conjunto de vectores propios
vamos a suponer que son de 1 b 2
así hasta
bn
que este conjunto es un conjunto de
vectores linealmente independientes y
que todos son vectores propios de a
ahora como son n de ellos y son
linealmente independientes esto también
formó una base para rn y ahora vamos a
ver que esa base es particularmente
interesante en cuanto a cómo se comporta
o cómo se representa la transformación t
respecto a esta base bien entonces como
se ve por ejemplo la transformación del
primer vector de esta base la
transformación aplicada al vector de uno
pues como es un vector propio de la
matriz de la transformación y de la
matriz en consecuencias 3 d v 1 es lo
mismo que a por b 1
qué es lo mismo que alguna escalar
lambda 1 por el vector de 1 porque de 1
es un vector propio de la matriz a bien
y que hay de b2 pues la transformación
aplicada al vector b 2 es lo mismo que
la matriz a por el vector de 2 que es lo
mismo que el hambra 2 por el vector de 2
y así podría continuar voy a continuar
haciendo esto para cada uno de estos
vectores
llegar al enésimo vector y decir que la
transformación aplicada el rector ven es
lo mismo que la matriz a por el vector
bn que es lo mismo que un escalar lambda
n por el vector de n recuerden que todos
estos son vectores propios de la matriz
a bueno ahora voy a hacer algo que
quizás se vea bastante tonto y es decir
pues esto es lo mismo que lambda 1 x b 1
+ 0 por b 2
+ 0 por b tres y así hasta cero por de n
y del mismo modo
esto es lo mismo que 0 por el vector b 1
+ lambda 2 por el vector b 2 más puro
ceros hasta 0 por el vector de n
y luego finalmente si hago eso con todos
los vectores obtengo que el enésimo
vector la transformación aplicable
enésimo vector es 0 por el vector b 1 +
0 por el vector b 2 y así hasta
lambda en por el rector de n recuerden
que esto es una base y quizá se estén
preguntando por qué agregue todos estos
ceros porque no simplemente deje las
cosas así pues lo que pasa es que ahora
quiero utilizar coordenadas con respecto
a esta base y ver cómo se comporta la
matriz que representa la transformación
t y estas son precisamente las
coordenadas de la imagen de estos
vectores así que hagamos eso vamos a
decir que mi base de rn es precisamente
esta base formada por n vectores propios
linealmente independientes de la matriz
a y entonces les recuerdo rápidamente si
yo tengo un vector x y lo multiplicó por
la matriz a lo que obtengo es la imagen
de x bajo la transformación te tengo te
de x y del mismo modo yo podría tener o
expresar a x en coordenadas respecto a
una base b
puedo pasar de las coordenadas estándar
a las coordenadas respecto a la base
utilizando la matriz de cambio base que
les recuerdo que es la matriz cuyas
columnas son precisamente los elementos
de mi base ve si quiero pasar de las
coordenadas estándar a coordenadas
respecto a la base ve multiplicó por la
inversa de la matriz de cambio base por
ser la menos 1 y si quiero pasar de
estas coordenadas a las estándar
simplemente multiplicó por la matriz de
cambio de base
ahora bien yo sé que aquí existe una
matriz d
de tal que al multiplicar el vector de
coordenadas de x respecto a la base b
por la matriz de obtengo las coordenadas
respecto a la base de la imagen del
vector x bajo la transformación te tengo
esto de aquí y de nuevo equipo cambiar
de base puedo
usar la inversa en la matriz de cambio
de base y la matriz de cambio de base
para cambiar de sistemas coordenadas
bien lo que vamos a ver es que cuando la
base en cuestión es esta base de
vectores propios de amd lo que pasa con
d es que es una matriz muy bonita es una
matriz por ejemplo diagonal y entonces
si por ejemplo yo quisiera aplicarle una
matriz de muchas veces a un mismo vector
entonces me conviene cambiar de
coordenadas y hacer este proceso de aquí
entonces vamos a ver cómo se ve esta
matriz de aquí precisamente bien
entonces lo que voy a hacer es escribir
esto de varias formas y comparar el
resultado ok entonces primero que nada
quiénes son las coordenadas de la imagen
de de uno respecto a la base de pues eso
por un lado es lambda uno por b uno las
coordenadas de lambda uno por b uno
respecto a la base b pero esos son los
coeficientes de esta combinación lineal
porque estos vectores son los vectores
que conforman la base así que esto
es lo mismo que el vector lambda 100000
en todos los demás lugares
estas son las coordenadas de la imagen
de v 1 bajo la transformación respecto a
la base b pero por otro lado eso es lo
mismo que una matriz d
la matriz de que voy a representar como
la matriz que tiene por columnas a los
vectores de uno de dos de tres y así
hasta de n
multiplicada por las coordenadas del
vector de uno respecto a la base b pero
las coordenadas del vector de uno
respecto a la base b simplemente son 100
0000 en todos los demás lugares porque
porque la combinación lineal de estos
vectores queme al vector de uno es uno
profe 10 por b 2 y así hasta 0 por 20 ok
pero este producto de matriz por vector
cuanto me da pues esto es 1 por de 1 que
es de 1
+ 0 x de 20 x de tres y así hasta cero
por de n
así que este resultado es de 1 bien y
voy a hacer lo mismo voy a hacer lo
mismo ahora con v2 así que quiénes son
las coordenadas respecto a la base de la
imagen debe 2 bajo la transformación t
pues pues son
en este caso están dados por de 2 a 0
por b 1 lambda 2 por b 2 y luego 0 en
todos los demás lugares hasta el enésimo
pero esto es lo mismo que la matriz de
que hemos quedado que era de uno de dos
así hasta de n
esta matriz por el vector de coordenadas
de veedor respecto a la base b pero eso
es cero veces de uno una vez de 20 veces
de tres y así hasta 0 veces b n
así que con toda esto pues esto es cero
por de uno más uno por de 2
+ 0 x de 3 etcétera etcétera y
finalmente finalmente vamos a hacerlo
así lo puedo hacer con todos hasta
hasta llegar a bn
quienes son las coordenadas del vector
de n de la imagen del vector b
respecto a la base b pues
de nuevo yo sé que 0 x 10 x b 2 y así
hasta lambda en forma de m
pero eso es lo mismo que la matriz de la
matriz de uno de dos
hasta
dn
por quién quién es el vector de
coordenadas de adn pues ahora es 0 x
b-10 b-20 por b 3
así hasta 1 por bn y esto
esto me da 0 x de 10 x de 2 así hasta 1
x de n
muy bien entonces quién es la matriz de
pues la matriz de tiene por primera
columna a de uno pero de uno es lambda 1
y luego pudo 000
si hasta la última fila bien luego por
segunda columna es de 2 pero ese 0 y
luego lambda 2 y luego puros ceros de
nuevo
y así así serían lambda 13 ya dando 3
aquí y luego dos ceros arriba y todos
los más ceros
y así continuaría hasta la enésima
columna donde sería lambda en el última
fila y puros ceros arriba de lambda en 0
y 0
así que esa es la matriz esa es la
matriz de muy bien así que esto es algo
bastante interesante que aprendimos hoy
esta es la gran la gran moraleja del
vídeo si suponemos o más bien si nuestra
matriz a tiene n vectores linealmente
independientes que ojo no siempre es el
caso no siempre habrán n vectores
propios linealmente independientes una
matriz tiene una infinidad de vectores
propios cuando tiene al menos uno no
trivial pero pero no siempre tiene n
vectores profesionalmente independientes
en el caso de que existan estos forman
una base de rm de hecho esta base b
también es una base de rm y la llamamos
la
base propia base propia
y entonces si tomamos la matriz que
representa la transformación t respecto
a esta base a esta matriz de aquí
entonces la matriz de tiene un montonal
de propiedades interesantes por ejemplo
estas matrices diagonales son muy fácil
de multiplicar muy fáciles de
multiplicar es muy fácil tomarles el
determinante o invertir las así que
tienen muchísimas propiedades bonitas y
esto es realmente la moraleja del vídeo
viene algo que es muy interesante es que
los vectores son abstracciones
matemáticas estos vectores con los que
trabajamos son abstracciones matemáticas
de cosas que podrían ser por ejemplo la
población en un lugar o quizás el clima
en algún punto de la tierra y entonces
lo que tenemos lo que tenemos son
funciones que van de un espacio a otro y
lo que acabamos de ver es que podemos
simplificar mediante los cambios de base
a la matriz que representa a estas
funciones entonces para dar un ejemplo
concreto podríamos pensar en una cadena
de marco donde la matriz a representa la
matriz que contienen las pruebas
desde pasar de un estado a otro y
entonces nos gustaría integrar esta
transformación para encontrar los
estados estables sé que no estoy
explicando nada de esto pero bueno es
solo para que se den una idea entonces
nos conviene más trabajar con esta
matriz de que son la matriz diagonal
porque la vamos a estar liderando
múltiples veces y entonces el cálculo se
simplifica si utilizamos esta matriz
diagonal en general el álgebra lineal es
una herramienta universal que puede
resolver toda clase de problemas y este
tipo de cosas las bases propias los
vectores propios los cambios de base las
matrices diagonales son sencillamente
formas de facilitarnos la vida en
cuestión de los cálculos